un tournoi international de tennis
fauteuil à feroll pendant 3 jours une
trentaine de joueurs de haut niveau se
sont affrontés sur les cours au comité
de tennis des Yveline un tournoi de
niveau itf3 avec une dotation à 14000
dollars qui fait la fierté des
organisateurs il rentre vraiment dans le
projet du du comité des ivlines qui
depuis plusieurs années est engagé dans
justement cette promotion et ce
développement du tennis fauteuil et nous
avons également nous sommes le seul
département au niveau national à avoir
une structure haut niveau où nous
justement nous entraînons Pauline Doulet
de la championne de France et qui était
13e mondial et puis Olivier
Langlois qui est numéro 7 français sur
le terrain pas de victoirees français
dans le tableau féminin Pauline doulette
qui s'entraîne au Comité des ivines a
perdu en demi-finale et Charlotte
faerban a perdu en finale face à la
chinoise chiaoui lit je suis hyper
contente du tournoi j'ai fait de très
bons matchs là surtout en finale j'ai
j'ai bien tenu par rapport à la semaine
dernière parce que c'était la même
finale la semaine dernière j'ai j'ai
beaucoup mieux joué je suis resté
beaucoup plus dans dans mon cadre chez
les hommes le français guilem lager
remporte la victoire face au Britannique
Denon Ward 63 62 c'est un tournoi très
relevé cette année c'était un grade
supérieur à celui de l'an dernier etah
il y avait beaucoup de de très bons
joueurs des joueurs du Top 20 des des
joueurs très bien classés j'ai réussi à
joué un très bon tennis cette semaine
donc je suis vraiment heureux après ce
tournoi de tennis fauteuil le comité des
organisera un autre événement
international la Winter Cup avec les
futurs espoirs féminins de la discipline
en février
prochain